The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HERBERT GROSS: Hi.
Today, we begin our
eighth and final block
of material in our course.
And since we began the
course with an emphasis
on structure, in
particular vector spaces,
it's only appropriate that we
conclude on the same level.
Now, you may recall,
when we first
started talking
about vectors, we
began with the rather simple
interpretation of arrows.
Then we got to
2-tuples and 3-tuples
to revisit what arrows
looked like numerically.
Then we generalized this
to n-dimensional n-tuples
so that we could talk about
functions of n real variables.
And what we did was we defined a
vector space to be the n-tuples
together with certain
structural properties.
And at the very end, we
then did the usual thing
that one does in a structure.
We showed what a
vector space would
look like without
reference to n-tuples.
Now what I'd like to
do in this lecture,
and emphasize this for the
remainder of our course,
is to show what vector spaces
would have looked like,
what enrichment we could
have gained if we had stuck
with our more generalized
axiomatic definition
in the first place.
And rather than go on
about this philosophically,
let me get to the gist of our
lecture today, which, as I say,
is simply called vector
spaces, but hopefully
from a perspective different
from what was had before,
that the structural axiomatic
definition, you'll recall,
was that V was called a
vector space with respect
to the real numbers R.
And I should mention
here that there
are places where one
might talk about a vector
space with respect to the
complex numbers C, or something
like this.
But, for our
purposes, we are going
to be content to stick with
what is called real vector
spaces, namely a vector
space with respect
to the real numbers.
And what were the
structural properties?
Well, the sum of two
vectors had to be a vector,
that the sum had to obey
the associative rule.
There had to be an
additive identity.
There had to be
additive inverses.
And the sum had
to be commutative.
We also had a scalar
multiplication structure,
if you'll recall, that said
that if a scalar multiplied
the sum of two vectors,
the distributive rule held,
namely that c times alpha
plus beta was c alpha
plus c beta, where
c was a real number.
And the distributive rule also
held if the sum of two numbers
was multiplying a
vector, you see,
where c1 and c2 here
are real numbers.
And, finally, if a scalar times
a scalar multiple of a vector
were given, this product
was also associative, namely
that c1 times the
vector c2 alpha
is the same as the scalar
multiple c1 c2 times alpha.
And, finally, that the number 1
multiplied by the vector alpha,
the scalar multiple 1 times
alpha, was still alpha.
In other words,
that the scalar--
that, with respect to
scalar multiplication,
1 still behaves like the
multiplicative identity.
And what we noted was that
the properties of n-tuples
were now theorems with respect
to the structural definition.
You see, we could show that if
alpha were an n-tuple, that 0
times alpha was 0 for
all n-tuples in V.
But now what we're saying is
we also showed at that time
that, axiomatically, one could
prove all of these results,
that the 0 scalar times
a vector was always 0.
The scalar c times the
0 vector was always
the 0 vector for all scalars.
That if alpha plus beta
equals alpha plus gamma,
beta equaled gamma.
The cancellation rule held.
If c times alpha
was 0, either c was
0 or alpha was 0,
et cetera, meaning,
we had all of these theorems.
And, just again by way of
refreshing your memories,
I very quickly jotted down
a semi-proof of this result,
namely, if c wasn't 0, knowing
that c times alpha was 0,
we multiply both
sides by 1 over c.
By the associative property,
I can group 1 over c with c.
And 1 over c times c is 1.
I also know that c
times 0 is still 0.
And in words, any real
number time the 0 vector
is still the 0 vector.
Putting all of this together,
you see I have what?
That regrouping
this in this form,
this must equal the 0 vector.
But this is 1 times
alpha equaling 0.
But by our ninth axiom,
1 times alpha is alpha.
Therefore, alpha equals 0.
And we can go on in this
particular way, re-deriving
all of the properties that we
previously talked about when
we were dealing with n-tuples.
The question that
comes up is, what's
so great about doing the same
thing in two different ways?
Why do we have to come back
to the structural definition
when the n-tuples were
working very nicely for us?
And what I'd like
to do is two things,
and I'm going to
introduce one new concept,
and let it drop fairly
rapidly, and then come back
to a older concept from
a new point of view.
In the first place, my claim is
that the axiomatic definition
of a vector space opens up
a whole new avenue of things
that we can call vector spaces
that we couldn't have called
vector spaces before, because
they couldn't be represented
as n-tuples, for example.
And let me just say that-- so
you see it written down here--
new definition permits
new vector spaces.
By way of example, let me
take the set of all functions
subject only to the condition
that they have a common domain.
For example, let's take
a set of all functions f
whose domain of definitions,
say, is the closed
interval from a to b.
In other words, all you
need to belong to the set V
is a function defined
for all real numbers
on the closed
interval from a to b.
Notice that, both in part 1
and part 2 of this course,
we had already defined
very special meanings
for what it meant by
the sum of two functions
and the scalar multiple of a
function, namely, by f plus g,
where f and g were functions
with a common domain,
and by c times f.
Recall our
definitions were what?
That f plus g of x is simply f
of x plus g of x, and cf of x
is simply c times
f of x, where x
is any number in the close
interval from a to b.
Notice, in terms of a
picture, what we're saying
is that, for the f plus g
machine, if the input is x,
the output is f
of x plus g of x.
For the cf machine,
if the input is x,
the output is c times f of x.
Notice that if f is defined
on the closed interval from a
to b, c times f is
defined on the closed
interval from a to b.
And if f and g have
a common domain,
in particular if
the domain happens
to be the closed
interval from a to b,
notice that x belongs to
both the domains of f and g,
and that, consequently,
this summation makes sense.
In other words, if
we had a number which
belonged to the domain of f
but not to the domain of g,
this wouldn't even be defined.
All right.
So here is a new
type of set that
doesn't look like n-tuples.
In other words, there
are a voluminous number
of independent functions which
are defined on some interval
from a to b.
But the key point is
that this new vector--
that this new set V
satisfies axioms 1
through 9 of our new definition
of our structural definition.
In other words, the
set of all functions
which are continuous--
I'm sorry-- which are defined
on the interval from a to b,
according to our
structural definition,
would also be a vector space.
In other words, our key point
is that the new definition
enlarges the concept
of a vector space,
where, by enlarges
the concept, I
mean it allows new animals
to get in to the definition,
that we have enlarged what can
now be called a vector space.
Let me pause here
for a moment just
to enforce one little
detail for you,
and that is keep in mind that
I am appreciative of the fact
that, probably, you are
not used to visualizing
a set of functions as
being a vector space.
Consequently, it's my
feeling that if I continue
harping on this particular
example, much of what I say
will be lost on you because you
haven't had enough time to have
this new concept sink in.
So what I'm going to do is to
leave a number of exercises
for our study
guide where you can
get adequate drill on what we
mean by this new type of vector
space.
What I'd like to do for the
next part of our lecture
is to get away from this new
concept, which, by the way,
is very important,
which we will emphasize
as the remainder of
this block continues.
But for those who say,
I'm not that interested
in functions as vector spaces--
I can't visualize that--
I would like to point
out a second key point.
And that is that even when
you deal with n-tuples,
the structural
definition has advantages
over the n-tuple definition.
In particular, which I
call key point number
2, the new definition--
and by new I
mean the structural
definition-- is
free of any dependence
of a coordinate system.
Now, what do I
mean by dependence
of a coordinate system?
Let's see if I can't
make that clear by means
of a particular example.
Let's suppose I'm
dealing in the--
I'm in the xy plane, and we're
used to the vectors i and j
as being the basic
vectors of the xy plane.
Let's assume for
the sake of argument
that, for one
reason or another--
and I'll clarify what
one reason or another
means as our course goes on.
But, for one reason
or another, let's
suppose that, for the
particular problems
I'm interested in,
the two vectors alpha
and beta, where alpha is defined
to be i plus j, and beta, say,
is defined to be
3i plus 2j, let's
suppose that the two
vectors alpha and beta
happen to be the
two vectors that we,
for some reason or
other, happen to be
more interested in than we
are interested in i and j.
Now, the idea is
something like this.
First of all, observe that,
because of the arithmetic,
the axioms that a
vector space satisfies,
I can treat alpha, beta, i
and j, the same as I would
real variables, so to speak.
And I can solve
algebraically for i
and j in terms of
alpha and beta,
which I've just done over here.
And I leave the details for you.
You just solve these as two
equations and two unknowns.
Solve for the i and j in
terms of alpha and beta.
Now the idea is this.
Let's suppose I'm
given some vector
v. For the sake of argument,
let v be the vector 4i plus 5j.
Now, notice that the
vector v is well defined,
and I'll show you that
pictorially in a few moments.
But that vector v
exists independently of
whether we talk about i
and j components or not.
In other words, once I tell
you that v is 4i plus 5j,
it exists as an
arrow in the plane.
And once I've drawn
that arrow, that arrow
is well defined even if I now
erase what this definition is.
The point I wanted to
make, though, is this.
You will recall that when
we dealt with 2-tuples,
we picked i and j as being
the important vectors,
and we abbreviated
v as 4 comma 5,
indicating that the
vector 4i plus 5j,
if it originated at
0, 0, would terminate
at the point 4 comma 5.
Now suppose, for the
sake of argument,
we were interested in v
not in terms of i and j
but in terms of the new
vectors alpha and beta.
Knowing that i is minus
2 alpha plus beta,
and j is 3 alpha minus beta,
by direct substitution,
we can replace i and j by
what they're equal to in terms
of alpha and beta.
So just by direct substitution.
And I can conclude--
again, notice the
arithmetic here.
You see 4--
I can multiply this out--
minus 8 alpha plus
4 beta, because I
have a rule that tells me that
a scalar times the sum of two
vectors is a scalar
times the first vector
plus a scalar times the
second vector, et cetera.
All the rules of
arithmetic apply here.
So I very quickly say 15 alpha
minus 8 alpha is 7 alpha.
4 beta minus 5
beta is minus beta.
So relative to alpha
and beta, notice
that v has the unique
representation 7 alpha
minus beta.
Now, suppose I wanted to
abbreviate v with reference
to the basis vectors
alpha and beta, where
the convention would be that I
would list the alpha component
first and the beta
component secondly.
Notice that the
2-tuple that names v
would be 7 comma minus 1.
See, 7 is the
coefficient of alpha.
Minus 1 is the
coefficient of beta.
7 comma minus 1
would be the 2-tuple
that represents v if
I use alpha and beta
as my representative vectors.
Whereas the 2-tuple
4 comma 5 represents
v with respect to the,
in quotation marks,
the "usual" representation
in terms of i and j.
Notice that v is
the same vector.
That hasn't changed.
But, certainly, the
2-tuple 7 comma minus 1
and the 2-tuple 4 comma
5 do not look alike.
In other words, there
is a big danger--
as, for one reason
or another, we
switch from different
representative vectors
to other, often a given set
of representative vectors
to another set of
representative vectors--
that we can become confused
as to which 2-tuple--
in this case, 2-tuple would
be n-tuple in general--
but which representation
goes with which 2-tuple.
See, the whole idea is that our
new definition, structurally,
never pays any attention to what
the particular representation
is.
And from the mathematician's
point of view,
what we feel is that what should
happen in the study of vector
spaces should be consequences
of the vectors, not
the particular
coordinate system.
And if that phrase
confuses you, I'm
using the coordinate system
in the following sense.
When I talk about i and
j, I think about i and j
as being my coordinate system.
When I talk about alpha and
beta, I think of alpha and beta
as being my coordinate system.
For example, given the vector
v, let's suppose this is alpha
and this is beta.
Notice that v certainly
is a linear combination
of alpha and beta.
In other words, it's this
vector plus this vector.
It's also a linear combination
of i and j, certainly
a different linear
combination of alpha and beta
than it is a linear
combination of i and j.
But also certain is the
fact that the representation
of v in terms of alpha and
beta as our coordinate system
is unique, just as
the representation
of v in terms of an i and j
coordinate system is unique.
In other words, v has
a unique representation
as some scalar multiple of alpha
plus a scalar multiple of beta.
But it also has a
unique representation
in the form a scalar multiple of
i plus a scalar multiple of j.
You see, we do not mean
that the representation
is unique in the sense they
can only be written as one
set of linear combinations.
What we mean is that, for
each coordinate system,
for each coordinate
system, there
is a unique representation
as a linear combination
of the coordinates, but
different coordinate systems
lead to different
linear combinations.
But the key point from the
mathematician's point of view
is that v exists independently
of the choices of alpha
and beta.
You see, again, we
ran into this problem
before when we talked about
the distance between two points
in a plane.
Certainly, the distance
between two points in a plane
was independent of what
coordinate system we used.
But with respect to
polar coordinates,
the recipe for finding the
distance between the two points
did not look the
same as the recipe
that one used for finding the
distance between the same two
points when the
points were expressed
in Cartesian coordinates.
The same thing
we're saying here.
We would like our mathematics
to depend only on the vectors,
not on their representation.
Well, enough said about
that part of the theory.
What we'd next--
again, the exercises
will hopefully fill
in any gaps that
may be missing in
the logical structure
from your point of view.
But the next thing
we'd like to talk about
is a thing called
a substructure,
that whenever one talks about
a new type of structure,
the concept of what we used to
call a subset becomes too weak,
and what one wants
to talk about,
then, is the concept
of a substructure.
What I mean by that is the
next topic I want to talk about
is called subspaces.
And to give you an idea
of what I'm talking about,
let's do the following.
Let's go back into the
plane and take just
the two individual
vectors i and j.
Not the whole plane,
just the two vectors--
the unit vector in the direction
of the positive x-axis,
of the positive y-axis.
Just these two vectors.
Now, certainly, the set
consisting of just these two
vectors is a subset of
two-dimensional vector space.
In other words, the set of
all vectors in the xy plane
certainly includes the i
vector and the j vector.
So it would certainly
be fair to say
that this set A is a subset of
two-dimensional vector spaces.
But the idea is that a
vector space has a structure.
We care much more about
how you combine vectors
and what you get
than we worry about
whether you just have a set.
Remember, mathematically,
a structure is what?
A set together
with certain rules.
And so what we're saying here is
look what goes wrong with this.
If we were looking at
this thing structurally,
one would say something
like, gee, let's add i and j.
If we add i and j,
we get i plus j.
i plus j is neither the
vector i nor the vector j.
In other words, in terms of a
picture, here's i, here's j.
What is i plus j?
i plus j is just the sum
of these two vectors.
What we're saying is i
and j belong to the set A,
but i plus j certainly
is neither i nor j.
Since they consist
solely of i and j,
the fact that i plus
j is neither i nor j
means that i plus
j does not belong
to A. And, similarly, neither
does, for example, twice i.
If I double i, I
get the vector which
has the same direction and sense
as i but it's twice as long.
Consequently, that vector
is neither i nor j.
So, in particular, given the
set whose only two elements are
i and j, notice that if I
add two vectors in the set A,
I need not get a
vector in the set A.
And if I take a scalar multiple
of any vector in the set A,
I need not get a
vector in the set A.
And so, structurally, this is
a bad thing, because notice
that, structurally, we
will be adding vectors.
Consequently, if
we start with a set
and add two members in that
set, and the resulting vector
can then be a vector
which isn't in that set,
we don't have a very
convenient structure.
So what we do is we
isolate a very key point.
And let me give you the
definition abstractly first,
and then show you in
terms of familiar examples
that we already knew this.
Let's suppose that we
have a vector space V
and that W is simply
a subset of V.
So this just means
subset so far.
Then W is called a
subspace of V provided
that, one, the sum of any
two elements in the subset W
is also an element in W. In
other words, that the subset
W is close with respect to
the addition operation that
makes V a vector space.
And, secondly, that, for
any element in the subset W,
any scalar multiple
of that element
is also in W. In other words, W
must also be close with respect
to that same scalar
multiplication with respect
to which V is defined.
And, by the way, I think if you
think about that for a while,
you will notice
that this is true.
For example, we have
often talked about a line
being a subset of a plane.
But in terms of
vectors, we could
have made a stronger
statement, namely
a line is a subspace
of the plane.
And, in a similar
way, a plane is
a subspace of
three-dimensional space,
namely, starting with a plane,
if you take two vectors which
lie in the plane
and you add them,
the sum of those two vectors
is still in the plane.
And if you take
a scalar multiple
of any vector in a plane,
the resulting vector
still lies in that plane.
So by means of a
few examples, then,
if V now is usual
three-dimensional Euclidean
space, if I let W be the set
of all linear combinations of i
and j--
and, by the way, contrast
that with the set W--
with the set A over here.
Notice that the set A
over here consisted only
of the vectors i and j.
The set W here consists of all
linear combinations of i and j.
In other words, it's all
vectors of the form c1 i plus c2
j, where c1 and c2
are real numbers.
And notice that W is
the entire xy plane.
And, after all, any
vector in the xy plane
can be written as a linear
combination of i and j.
Why is this a subspace?
Well, leaving the
details to you,
notice, first of
all, that it's clear
that this should
certainly be a subset,
namely every vector
in here is a vector
that belongs to
three-dimensional space
even though it lies in a plane.
But notice that the sum of any
two linear combinations of i
and j is again a linear
combination of i and j.
And any scalar multiple of a
linear combination of i and j
is again a linear
combination of i and j.
So W satisfies the criteria
for being a subspace.
In other words, W is not
only a subspace in this case.
W is the xy plane.
By the way, using the alpha and
beta of the previous example,
notice that if I let V again
be three-dimensional space
and pick alpha to be i plus
j, and beta to be 3i plus 2j,
notice that if I take the set
of all linear combinations
of alpha and beta,
then W is also a plane,
and it's called the plane
spanned by or determined
by alpha and beta.
In other words, it's the
plane that has alpha and beta
as consecutive edges
of a parallelogram.
By the way, let me
make two comments here.
First of all, if these d's
look funny to you, they should,
because just before the
lecture began, these were c's.
And I changed these c's to d's
because the mathematician would
have no danger in confusing
the coefficients here
with the coefficients here,
but for the uninitiated I think
it's very important to
make this observation.
Notice that alpha
and beta, being
linear combinations of i and
j, both lie in the xy plane.
Consequently, the plane
determined by alpha and beta
is also the xy plane.
This, in turn, means that, in
both of these two examples,
W is the xy plane.
But, somehow or
other, you wouldn't
expect that W would be the same
linear combination of alpha
and beta as it is of i and j.
And, therefore, I prefer to
use different letters here
to indicate that a
given vector in V
might require two
numbers c1 and c2
to be coefficients of i
and j, but, with respect
to alpha and beta,
two different numbers.
OK?
That's one point I wanted
to make about this.
The other point I wanted to
make about this, you see,
notice that alpha and beta
don't look like i and j,
and there's a danger--
that you may not even realize
when you see alpha and beta--
that alpha and beta determine
the same plane as i and j.
Now, you see, that
leads to the problem
that we were talking
about before,
namely, given the same plane,
the representation of the plane
looks different if you use one
set of representative vectors
than if you use another set
of representative vectors.
But, more importantly,
let me point out
that there was nothing sacred
about the xy plane here.
Just to change this
problem ever so slightly,
let me add on a plus k,
say, to both alpha and beta.
That makes this a
new example, you see.
Let alpha be i plus j plus k.
Let beta be 3i plus 2j plus k.
Notice that alpha and beta are--
neither is in the xy plane.
They are not parallel to one
another, because this is not
a constant multiple of this.
Therefore, notice that alpha
and beta are still two vectors.
W is still the set of all
linear combinations of these two
vectors.
See, this part doesn't change.
And W now is still the plane
spanned by alpha and beta,
but now notice that the plane
spanned by alpha and beta
is the plane which has alpha
and beta as consecutive edges,
the parallelogram determined
by the plane that has alpha
and beta as consecutive edges.
And this parallelogram clearly
is no longer in the xy plane.
All right.
And now, for a finale for
today, what I'd like to do now
is to point out, going
back ever so briefly
to our first key point, that
there are vector spaces which
aren't viewed as n-tuples,
namely, for example,
the set of all functions
defined on the closed interval
from a to b.
Let me show you what
subspaces mean in terms
of this interpretation.
My next example, again let V
be, as earlier in the lecture,
the set of all functions
having a common domain,
say the closed
interval from a to b.
Let's look now at the set
W1 of all functions which
not only are defined on the
closed interval from a to b,
but they happen to be
continuous on the closed
interval from a to b.
You see, notice that,
originally, I never had
to assume continuity here.
As long as the
function is defined
on the closed
interval from a to b,
I can add any two
members of this family.
I can scalar multiply any
member of this family.
So I do not need continuity to
have this be a vector space.
However, suppose I now
look at all functions which
are continuous on the
closed interval from a to b.
Well, in particular,
it should be
trivial to see that this set W
sub 1 is a subset of V, namely
every function which is
continuous on the closed
interval from a to b, in
particular, must be defined
on the closed
interval from a to b.
Consequently, every
function in this set
certainly belongs to this set.
On the other hand,
notice that we already
know that the sum of
continuous functions
is again a continuous function.
A scalar multiple of
a continuous function
is again a continuous function.
Consequently, according to
our definition of subspace,
W1 is not only a subset
of V. It's a subspace of V
because it's closed
with respect to--
excuse me-- addition and
scalar multiplication.
As another example,
let V be the same
as it was in the
previous example,
namely the set of all
functions defined on the closed
interval from a to b.
And now let's take
that subset consisting
of all functions which are
differentiable on the closed
interval from a to b.
In other words, this is
an even stronger condition
than being continuous.
We say not only must the
functions be continuous,
but now we want it to be
differentiable as well.
Remember, differentiability
implies continuity,
but continuity does not
imply differentiability.
All I'm saying now is
that, since the sum of two
differentiable
functions is again
a differentiable function,
and since a scalar
multiple, a constant times
a differentiable function,
is still differentiable, not
only is W2 a subset of V.
It's a subspace of V. In fact,
W2 is also a subspace of W1.
Recall, W1 was what?
The set of continuous functions
on the interval from a to b.
That was also a vector space.
And now what we're
saying is that
the differentiable
functions are a subspace
of the continuous functions.
Again, I'm going to emphasize
all of this in the exercises,
and we'll pick this up
in more detail next time,
but what I wanted to close with
is simply the following remark.
If you have studied
calculus in the past
and have been away
from it for a while,
and you pick up an
ultra-modern calculus book,
you may be surprised to find
that even elementary calculus
begins with a preface
to emphasizing
what's called linear
algebra or vector spaces.
And the reason for this is
the fact that all of calculus,
going back to part
1 of our course,
does deal with continuous
and differentiable functions.
And, in particular, continuous
and differentiable functions,
as we've just shown, obey the
structure of a vector space.
And, consequently, that's
why many modern authors
prefer to unify the
approach to calculus
and introduce vector spaces
right at the very outset.
But we'll talk about this
more gradually as we go along.
And until next
time, then, goodbye.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.